justin trudeau you know my feelings
about justin trudeau and as jordan
peterson says justin trudeau
fundamentally cannot say anything true
he is the worst sort of authoritarian i
wear a nice suit i have a nice haircut
oh look at my pink socks i love the
lgbtq lmnop people who will gladly use
the government to take you
out and if you don't believe me listen
to this zinger
and there are debates and we have a
culture where the difference is guns can
be used for hunting or for sport
shooting in canada and there's lots of
gun owners and they're
mostly lost respecting and law abiding
but you can't use a gun for
self-protection in canada that's not a
right that you have in the constitution
or anywhere else if you try and buy a
gun and say it's for self-protection no
you don't get that you get it for
hunting you can get it for sport
shooting take it to the range no problem
as long as you go through our rigorous
background checks but there's a
difference around the culture and one of
the things that we're seeing with the
debate in the states is you get more and
more of the american style you know
right to carry self-defense arguments
filtering up through through the uh you
know the usual more right-wing
communications channels yeah
i would like to say as a leader of the
right-wing communications channels thank
god for the constitution of the united
states thank god for the bill of rights
thank god for the second amendment thank
god for all of the people who proudly
defend it thank god for those ideas that
are still percolating to our north so
the average canadian can realize that
that guy wants all the guns and wants to
be able to make sure you can't protest
or shut down your bank account or
everything else but how insane you can't
use a gun for self-protection
you can't according to him in canada you
can't so someone can break into your
house and maybe you have a gun there
because you hunt elk or deer up in
canada right you can't use that gun to
defend yourself the state should only
have guns that's the way he wants it